when you saw the movie surrogates you
said well that science fiction when
Bruce Willis has a mechanical robot who
is perfect absolutely perfect handsome
with superpowers and you put your
consciousness into the robot so you go
into a pod your body ages your body is
strapped to a pod but you mentally
control an avatar a surrogate who is has
superpowers perfectly formed and has all
your abilities this sounds like science
fiction right or the movie Avatar where
again you're put inside a pod and you
control an alien being on another planet
breathing poisonous air is that possible
and the answer is definitely yes
in Japan scientists at Honda Corporation
has made a robot called azzam Oh is one
of the most advanced robots ever made as
a mode the size of a young boy can run
walk climb up stairs and even dance if a
key dances better than me I've been on
science specials with him and he odd
dances me every time
Hunter corporation is now taken a worker
put on an EEG helmet and have him
control the robot so it's not possible
that you can have a surrogate this could
be the future of the space program
why is outer space not opened up for
tourists because of a dirty four-letter
word that begins with C cost it costs
$10,000 to put a pound of anything in
near Earth orbit that is your weight in
gold think of your body made out of
solid gold that's what it costs to put
you in near-earth orbit to put you on
the moon cost about a hundred thousand
dollars a pound and to put you on Mars
is about a million dollars a pound so
you're talking about your weight in
diamonds to go to the planet Mars why
not put a surrogate because it's life
support life support that makes things
so expensive and out of space
you see robots don't have to breathe
they don't have to eat they don't
bellyache and most important they don't
have to come back so why not put
surrogates on Mars surrogates on the
moon and you the astronaut can just take
a breather and go into your living room
and mentally communicate with a robot on
the moon this would be by far the
cheapest way to have a permanent moon
base and that would be to you at the
astronaut communicating with the
surrogate by radio